PROFESSOR: So today's class we
talked about vertex unfolding,
unfolding orthogonal
polyhedra, and something else
which there weren't
any questions
about-- got them already--
Cauchey's rigidity theorem.
So we will go through
those in turn.
A bunch of small
questions and two
cool new things, new updates.
So first question is
about vertex unfolding.
Why do we fold things
in a chain and kind
of a line, linear style?
Would you get any
benefit out of a tree?
The answer is chains are
easy to avoid intersection.
That's the reason we use them
on these kinds of unfoldings.
We could dedicate a different
slab for every piece
and this is great.
And incidentally-- I didn't
mention this in lecture,
but it's obvious once you think
about it for five minutes.
If you want general cuts-- if
you're allowed to cut anywhere
on the surface and you want
a vertex unfolding-- then
anything is possible because
you could take any surface
and chainify it in the same
way we do with the [INAUDIBLE]
sections.
You subdivide.
First, you triangulate.
You subdivide each triangle
into three triangles.
Then you can hinge it
together in a chain.
And then you can just
lay it out like this.
So general vertex unfolding
is trivial for this reason.
When you're only allowed
to cut along edges,
things get much harder.
The only technique we have right
now is facet path unfolding.
But of course, vertex
unfolding convex polyhedra
is an easier version of edge
unfolding context polyhedra,
but we have no idea
how to do that.
So maybe it's possible.
We already know it's not
possible with chains.
So if it's possible, it's
somehow possible with trees,
I guess.
We know tree style
unfoldings can
be helpful with
general cuttings,
but this is not directly
relevant to vertex unfolding.
But this is the source unfolding
and the star unfolding again.
So yeah, who knows?
But so far, chains are just
a useful proof technique.
All right, next question.
This is vertex
unfolding summarized
in the lecture notes
on the right side.
So we end up with a
nice Eulerian graph.
In this case, every vertex
happens to have even degree.
In general, two of them
might have odd degree
and we just get a path.
But the observation in
this question-- maybe
I'll go to the other side
so you can read both--
is that we visit the same
vertex multiple times,
like we attach these two
triangles at this vertex.
We also attach these two
triangles at that vertex.
Is that OK?
Yes, we define it to be OK.
I think I briefly mentioned
it's defined to be OK.
Why?
I don't know.
It's hard to imagine
little dots of paper there,
but somehow you imagine that
they can stay connected.
In particular, it's
the natural definition
of a hinge dissection.
You could add hinges
at those two places.
But also it's
impossible otherwise.
This was a fun little
puzzle to think about.
But if you take-- I actually
have a slide for it.
I don't have to draw.
It's hard to draw
an icosahedron.
If you take an icosahedron,
it has 20 faces.
And the dual is a dodecahedron
so it has 12 vertices.
So there aren't
enough to go around,
at least if you wanted
a chain unfolding.
Well, actually any
tree unfolding,
if you have 20
triangles, you're going
to need 19 vertices to
connect them together.
And there's only 12
vertices so you can't do it.
Is that literally true?
I guess you could imagine,
in a general tree unfolding,
you could use one point
to connect together
many triangles.
But I'm pretty sure
it's not possible
if you're allowed
to reuse vertices.
So that's why we allow it.
We get a more
interesting result when
we allow revisiting vertices.
Could be still an
interesting question like,
which polyhedron have
vertex unfolding if we only
get to use the vertex once?
But I don't know
any results on it.
Next question is, any
progress on vertex unfolding?
And there's one new result.
Before I showed you, I think,
one example of a vertex
ununfoldable polyhedron--
this guy, box on a box.
Initially, we said oh,
this is edge ununfoldable,
but it's also vertex
ununfoldable because this face
here is a donut and the
five sides of that cube
have to fit in here, and there's
not enough area for them.
And that's true also if
you're vertex unfolding.
No matter how this stays
attached to the donut face,
it's got a line here,
that's not possible.
But this is an
unsatisfying example
because you have a face
that is not a disk.
And in general, you're
not topologically convex.
you can't just move the vertices
around and make this a convex
polyhedron, not
strictly convex anyway.
So here is a new
example with Zach Abel.
He took this class
two years ago,
or five years ago, I guess.
This is a topologically
convex polyhedron,
so you could move the
vertices to make this convex.
That's not so obvious.
And it is vertex ununfoldable,
which we will prove.
This is one of the
two results for today.
The example is a dark prism
here, a triangular prism,
and a light triangular
prism just at right angles
to each other.
Then you take the
union of that solid,
and then you take the boundary.
So first, you can check
all the faces are disks.
And for topological
convexity, you
want to check that if
you look at any two faces
like this light S1
and this dark one,
they should only share
one edge at most.
They should share nothing,
a vertex, or an edge.
That's topological
convexity because that's
how things work in convex
if the polygons were convex.
So like here, they
share just that edge.
So it is topologically convex.
Let's prove that it is
vertex ununfoldable.
So in some sense, this is a
strengthening of the witch's
hats and stuff because this
is also edge ununfoldable.
But it's even cooler.
It's vertex ununfoldable.
Let's just look
at the connections
between the dark and the light.
There are one, two, three,
four vertices on this side
and four vertices
on the backside that
connect dark to light.
I should make some Star
Wars reference I suppose.
All those vertices
are symmetric,
so we can just look
at any of them.
Somewhere, the light side has
to be attached to the dark side.
Where could that be?
Let's say vertex A because
it's got to be somewhere,
and it's symmetric.
So vertex A has three
angles incident to it.
There's alpha-- that's
this angle-- which is big.
It reflects.
There's this beta and
there's this gamma.
Beta is 90 degrees
here because this
is supposed to be a rectangle.
Gamma is well, let me state
what I want from these angles.
There's some parameters
in the construction
I haven't yet told you.
So we want alpha to
be bigger than 270.
Theta equals 92.
And we want alpha plus
gamma equal to 360.
So this is possible if you
angle these guys correctly,
is the short version.
I guess the most
interesting is this alpha
plus gamma equals 360.
Is that obvious?
Not especially, but I'm claiming
it's true in this picture.
We'll see it in an
unfolding, actually,
on the very next slide.
Yeah, let's go there.
Still have the same picture.
But when unfolded, it's
supposed to look like this.
So what happens at A?
If you want to connect the
light side which is alpha
that's forced, you can
attach by a vertex unfolding
to beta or gamma.
Well, beta is impossible
because 90 plus greater than 270
is greater than 360.
So you would get overlap
locally at this vertex
if you attach these even
if you're vertex unfolding.
So you've got to
attach the gamma.
Alpha plus gamma is
supposed to be exactly 360.
And so vertex unfolding
doesn't buy you anything.
In order to not
locally overlap here,
they must fit right like that.
Then the only other
condition we need
is that these prisms
are long enough
so that you get
overlap over here.
So it's not a purely
local overlap,
but it's very close by.
It's the same two faces overlap.
Here, they happen to
overlap here and here.
If this were shorter, if
this were like this short--
this is the length
of the prism here--
then you'd avoid overlap.
And that's this picture.
So this is an unfolding of
one of the two prism halves.
This is unfolding of the other.
If you attach them, these
vertices as is necessary,
you get overlap.
Unless the prism
were short, then you
would get this
kind of unfolding.
So that's the proof.
You can actually make the proof
even simpler, kind of nifty.
Although it's less obvious
that this example exists.
You can give the coordinates
and you can check it exactly
and it has all the
properties you want.
Each prism has been
bent a little bit.
More or less the
same example, but now
it has the feature that
alpha plus beta prime is
greater than 360, and
alpha plus gamma prime
is greater than 360.
So you just can't
attach anything.
Even locally, you
get pure overlap.
So easy to check if
you're a computer.
Easier to check and proof and
verify if you're a computer.
Less easy visually.
So that's what's known.
Open problem-- which I
should probably write down--
is if your faces
are convex polygons,
is there a vertex
ununfoldable polyhedron?
That, we still don't know.
So the witch's hat, all
the faces are triangles.
There's no edge unfolding,
but it has a vertex unfolding.
These guys are nice.
They're topologically
convex, but the faces
are still very nonconvex.
And we use that because we want
a giant angle, a reflex angle
together with something to
add up to more than 360.
If you're always adding
up two convex angles,
you don't get that.
But maybe you could combine
it with a polyhedron that's
not Hamiltonian, so you have
to have three things joining it
together and then you
could get more than 360?
I don't know.
It could be an interesting
problem to work on.
But so far, it is open.
So that is vertex unfolding.
Next question is about
general unfolding
of nonconvex polyhedra.
Still it's open whether
every polyhedron, say
without boundary, has
a general unfolding.
Still we know that all
orthogonal polyhedra
of genus zero have an unfolding.
That remains the
state of the art.
But we have a
better way to unfold
orthogonal polyhedra
of genus zero.
And this is a new paper.
It's not yet online
but it will be shortly.
The final version just
went to the journal.
"Unfolding Orthogonal Polyhedra
with Quadratic Refinement."
So two of the same authors--
Mirela Damian and Robin
Flatland from the
exponential unfolding.
You may recall, we saw
a solution in lecture
that has exponential refinement.
The number of cuts in particular
can be exponential in n
in the worst case.
This requires you take the grid.
You refine it, at most,
quadratic number of times
in each dimension.
So the number of
cuts is polynomial,
I guess at most, and to
the seventh if you've got
n squared by n squared
by n squared by n.
I think it's actually
much less than that.
Probably more like n squared,
but I need to be careful.
So I want to cover
this solution.
It's a simple variation
actually on the previous one,
but also there's some
questions about how
the exponential one works.
I want to go through
that one more time.
We have new figures
for it from this paper.
So it looks a little different,
maybe a little bit clearer.
That was our girl.
I need my hands.
Remember, the general idea
was to slice your polyhedron
in one direction so you end
up with these bands, strips.
And then you visit the
strips in a treelike fashion.
And in particular,
at the leaves,
like the closest to
you, you've got a band
and then you've
got a front face.
And so that would look
something like this little box.
So you've got a band that
goes around-- which way is it?
Band is this way it.
Should be an x and z.
And then there's
the front face which
here is drawn on the back.
Those are the five out
of six faces of the box
that are actually present.
This face that's closest
to us is actually
attached to another band.
You could have leaves on
this side or that side.
So what do we do?
We enter at S and
we exit at T. And we
are told that the first
turn you make from S
should be a right turn.
And the last turn before
T should be a left turn.
And you start in
the unfolding, you
will start going
vertical on S, that's
why you should turn
right because we never
want to turn left.
We never want to go left in
the unfolding, which is here.
And we also want to end in
the vertical state for T
so that we can chain
these together.
So we started S. We're told to
turn right, which we do here.
Then we're basically
going to zigzag.
And if you check along this
surface, we turn right.
We go here, up there.
And then we turn
left, and then right.
And then this is a
left because we're
supposed to be
doing it from below.
And then a right with that
red thing, then a left, right,
down here, and a
left, and we're done.
And the number balances
out, so we start vertical,
we end vertical.
And then when we're done with
all these things, we thicken.
It's not drawn here, but
these strips get thickened.
And you end up attaching
these fatter versions,
but basically you're
following the same path.
We don't thicken
it at the beginning
because we're
actually going to do
this many times
on the same cell.
And then we abstract
that picture
to this iconography which says--
this I didn't talk about much
in lecture, which
says, you should
start by turning right
in S, and then you
should end by turning
left and then visiting T.
So that's one picture.
But it depends
where you're going.
There are actually eight
different versions.
I showed you this one.
But all those combinations
have to happen.
And the top ones are when
you're all the way forward.
The bottom ones are where
you're all the way back
in these slabs, so that's
slightly different.
And then there's whether S is on
the left or S is on the right,
relative to T. And then
there's whether you
start by turning to
the right from S or end
by turning to the left.
T is always the opposite.
But those are the
eight possibilities
from three different choices.
Are you far forward?
Are you far back?
Do you turn right from
S or do you turn left?
And is S to the left
or is S to the right?
That's why you have
eight combinations.
They all look
basically the same,
but those are your base cases.
So this is still all
review of the old version.
And then the last part of
the old method is non-leaves.
So in general, you
have a band which
is here drawn as
two separate pieces,
but really this is one band.
The bands are easy to unfold.
They go straight.
But then you have
all these children.
So you have your parent
which is the S and T part.
You have to start
here and end here.
Recursively, you want to
visit this whole subtree.
So you might have children that
are on the front side, children
that are on the backside.
And again, we're told we
should initially turn right.
So if we turn right, we
visit the first thing.
We tell this leaf or
this child, actually--
this is not necessarily a leaf.
We tell this child that the
next thing we want to do
is turn to the left because
we just turned right.
Actually, we just
turned right twice,
so we've just gone right, right.
We'll actually be
unfolding initially up,
so we turn right twice.
Now, we better
turn left and then
we will end up pointing
I believe down,
because initially this
was pointing down.
After you do this construction,
you'll be pointing down again.
And that's why you
want to turn left here.
So you unroll this thing.
You can verify you are
actually just zigzagging.
And so you go back and
forth through these.
Verify this always
proceeds to the right.
But we're using different
iconography here.
This is an S on the left
that initially turns left.
This is an S on the right
that initially turns right.
That's why we need the different
forms of the recursive call.
This is a picture where
initially we turn right on S
and S is to the right, but
there are different versions
of this picture just
like in the base cases
where S is to the left
and where you initially
have to turn left.
But they look the same.
You just visit them back
and forth like this.
At some point, you finish
the front children.
Then you go up.
And here, it's a
little bit shifted
but these would
normally be aligned.
Then you have to visit
the top children.
You do that by visiting
and going back and forth.
Then, of course, when
you're done here,
you have to unwind
everything you did.
Then we go over here.
We visit that guy,
back and forth.
Eventually, we will end
up on the inside here,
and having doubled everything,
we come back out to T.
And all the time, we're
unfolding to the right.
Now, what can we say about this?
Well, what sucks is all of these
children get visited twice.
And that's why you're doubling
at every recursive level.
And so if your recursion tree
looks like a long binary tree,
then you get exponential.
Not quite.
We'll come back to that.
Here's an example of
it being exponential
with this kind of tree.
It's a little hard to
draw too many levels deep.
So we have one level deep
and then another level deep.
But you'll notice
that it's not uniform.
This leaf gets visited
exponentially many times,
but this one still
only got visited once.
Of course, it's shallower.
But even these two leaves
are at the same level
and they did not get visited
the same number of times.
So there's some hope
of improving things
as you might imagine.
So this is where we go.
There's two observations
here, two ideas.
Maybe I'll tell you
where we started.
I was I think-- I can
never remember years.
I was teaching this class
either two or five years ago
and I had idea number one.
And we worked on it in
the open problems session,
but it was not enough.
Idea number one is
just part of the story.
And it's an idea that comes
from the other graduate
class I teach which is
heavy-light decomposition
and advanced data structures.
So this is a very
common technique
in advanced data structures.
It goes back to
Sleator and Tarjan,
if you've ever heard of splay
trees or link-cut trees.
It's that era which was
the '80s, I believe, '83.
It's a very useful tool.
Whenever you have
general tree structure
and you want to
make it balanced,
you should think
heavy-light decomposition.
There are actually a few
ways to balance a tree,
but heavy-light decomposition
is usually the most powerful.
So essentially
what it does is say
if I could just treat
this thing, this path
as a single node, and then treat
these guys as separate nodes,
then I'd kind of be balanced.
It would be like one super node
and then a bunch of children
hanging off of it.
One, two, three, four.
So that's the picture
I'd like to make.
I'm going to contract paths,
only paths of my tree.
And it turns out
there's always a way
to take paths, contract
them into single nodes,
so that the resulting thing
has height at most log n,
no matter what tree
you start with.
And heavy-light decomposition
is a way to do this.
It's very simple to define.
For every node, you define
the idea of a heavy child.
This is a child with more
than half the weight.
The weight of a subtree is the
number of descendant nodes,
so the number of
nodes in that subtree.
So if we look at this
picture, you've got this node.
It has one, two, three, four,
five, six, seven, eight,
nine nodes below it.
This subtree only has one,
so this subtree has seven.
Seven is bigger
than half of nine.
Most of the weight
is to the left.
So we call this edge heavy.
Similarly, this edge is
heavy because this is five.
Five is more than half of seven.
This one's only
three nodes below it.
That is still more than half
because half of this is 2.5.
So this edge is heavy.
This one is not heavy.
So actually, in
the real picture,
it would look like this.
This is a heavy path and
this guy's all by itself,
so there's one more node.
But it has the same effect
of balancing the tree.
So what's the point?
In general, I have some tree.
In general, I might
have many children.
No idea how many
children are out there.
So every node can
have many children
and these correspond to
the various bands that
are attached to my parent band.
So that's heavy child.
In general though, every node
has at most one heavy child
because you can't have
more than two halves.
If I have more than half
of the weight in one child,
I can't have more than half of
the weight in another child.
So every node has at
most one heavy child.
These edges connecting nodes
and their heavy children
we call heavy edges.
And whenever we
have a node, there's
at most one heavy edge
going down from it,
so heavy edges form heavy paths.
That's the point.
So this red thing is
called a heavy path.
Cool.
So what do we know
about heavy paths?
The other edges, I
should say, these guys,
we call light edges.
This is the heavy-light
decomposition,
so every edge is
either heavy or light.
It could be a node
only has light children
because it's well-distributed.
In the worst case, it
has one heavy child,
one heavy edge coming out of it.
So we get heavy paths.
I guess I'll say heavy
edges form paths.
And if we look at
what I normally
call the light depth
of a node, this
is if I look at a
node in this tree
and I measure how
many light edges do
I have to traverse in order to
get from the root of the tree
to that node, here it's
only one light edge.
The number of light edges follow
on any path is at most log n,
log base 2 of n, because every
time I follow a light edge,
I know that I started
with say end nodes.
I follow a light edge.
I know that I have at most half
n nodes because my weight goes
down by half.
If I start with n, I can only
reduce by a factor of 2 log n
times before I run out of nodes.
Then I'm in a leaf when I get
down to the weight of one.
So light depth of any
node is at most log n
because weight halves every
step, every light step.
So this is why, if you
contract the heavy paths
to single nodes, the depth
of the remaining tree
is only log n.
So what does this tell us?
If I could somehow
deal with paths
efficiently and not
feel the recursive pain
that we're getting here
from doubling everything
along a path, then I
can chain them together
in the usual bad recursive way.
I can afford to double
on a balance tree.
So if I could somehow treat
these paths as single things,
we'd be all set.
That was idea number one
and that sat for years.
I knew this should be possible.
But what we were missing
was idea number two.
It's funny.
If you stare at this
picture long enough,
it's actually kind of obvious.
It requires more
work after the idea.
So here, the same
picture as before.
I spread it out a little bit.
So we end up visiting
this guy last.
And then we end up
recursively visiting this one
a second time, then
this one a second time,
then this one a second time.
We go down here.
We go around here.
Visit this one a second time.
Unwind.
Visit this one a second
time, this one a second time,
this one a second
time, and we're up.
Did I visit them
all a second time?
No.
There's one that I didn't
visit a second time, which
is the last child.
I only visited that one once.
And that's all we need is
one child because I only
need to do a path efficiently.
So I'm recursively visiting
most of the children here.
Those are going to
be my light children.
The one heavy
child, I want to aim
to visit that one last because
that one's only visited once
so it doesn't get recursively
doubled at this level.
Of course, the higher up the
level, it will get doubled.
But there's only log n levels
we're going to get doubled,
so we'll only add a factor of n.
Idea number two is that the
last child gets visited only one
at this recursive level.
And if you've taken
an algorithms class,
you know recursively
visiting things
once versus twice
makes a big difference.
Here it's a matter of doubling
or just staying the same.
If we can rearrange to visit
these children first, then do
this one last, then visit
this child first, then do
this one last, and then do all
the children in whatever order,
then we'll guarantee that this
path doesn't get recursively
refined at this
level so it's really
being treated as a
single node basically.
And that lets you tie
together these unfoldings
in an efficient way.
The only issue is I need to be
able-- this construction isn't
enough because this construction
basically forced this one
to be the last child
to get visited.
I need to be able to
control which child is last
visited because the
heavy property is
a property of the tree.
One of these guys,
maybe this one is heavy.
Maybe that one's heavy.
We've got to be
able to end on that.
So there are two cases.
First case is that we always
start from the bottom here.
And first case is
that on the top side
is where the heavy child is.
So this is the easy case because
the bottom, we don't care.
We just visit the children
in whatever order's natural.
Then we come up.
And basically, we have the
freedom to spin around here.
We have to turn
left, but we could
either choose to immediately
go up here or keep going
and go up here, or keep
going and go up here.
That would visit
that one too early.
Or go here.
Turns out this is
the right choice.
But we had freedom to just
spin around and choose
when to go up.
Just try them all.
One of them will
end up being last.
Basically, you
want this guy to be
in the middle between
where you start
and the one just to the
left here because you're
kind of rainbowing
back and forth,
zeroing in on the last guy.
And just by pigeonholing, I
suppose, one of these choices
will work because there's
k choices you could make
on when to turn up that each
result in a different guy being
last.
And so one of them corresponds
to the correct one.
That's easy to figure
out which one it is.
So if it's on the top
side, it's really easy.
You just pick it.
This would be great.
This would actually give
us linear refinement
if we only had this case.
The other case is when the
guy we want to make last,
the heavy child, is
on the bottom side.
In this case, we
need to do more work.
So this is basically
the old construction.
Here we don't really
have freedom from S.
We can't just bypass this
guy because it will actually
be hard to get him later.
So we've got to visit
him and back and forth.
But the one thing we could
do is just omit a child,
just forget about
it for a while.
Don't visit it.
Visit everything else
in whatever order
feels natural to you.
And then we're going
to splice this guy in.
So we'll see where
does the path go.
At some point, it will go
above this proposed last guy.
And what we're going to do,
which is on the next slide,
is on the return trip-- so
remember we have this picture.
We come out here.
Then we recursively
double everything.
So at some point, we are
coming here, doubling.
And at that point, we turn in.
But if S and T are
aligned like this,
we are pointing the wrong way.
We want it to get here,
but it doesn't even
look like we're
in the same side.
But we are.
We just have to recursively
double everything again.
In the end, when you recursively
double everything again,
you will be here.
And we haven't
finished doubling here.
But in the end, you will
come out here and exit at T.
So overall, these guys which
haven't been visited yet,
they'll end up being
doubled from this procedure.
These guys will end
up being quadrupled.
So we're doing four recursive
calls for most of the children.
Some of them might get
lucky and only double.
But all we care about is if
this guy only gets visited once.
That's the key.
Because this will
be recursively here.
It's hard to unwind.
But then you'll end up on
the inside of this channel.
Then you'll end up
visiting this guy.
And then you get out at T.
So you won't come back to here.
That's the key.
That's all we need.
You can write down a
recurrence at this point.
If you look at the
level of refinement
for an n vertex polyhedron
or an n slab polyhedron,
it would be-- n, we'll
say is the number of nodes
in the tree of
slabs, this picture.
In general, that is
proportional to the number
of vertices in the polyhedron.
In the worst case, it's going
to be the max of two things-- R
n minus 1, and 4
times R of n over 2.
Well, I should say
n sub i, max over i.
So what I mean to say here--
this is also technically an sub
i.
This is an upper
bound certainly.
So if we look at the recursion,
how much refinement we need,
the worst refinement
over the whole tree
is the max of all
of its subtrees.
So there's a [INAUDIBLE] here, a
[INAUDIBLE] here, and then also
of course, what we need
to do within the node.
And on the one hand,
there's the heavy situation,
the heavy edge.
That only decreases the
size of the tree by 1.
But it only gets
recursively visited
one time, 1 times
R of n minus 1.
There's the other
light children.
These are all light children.
n sub i represents the number
of nodes in that child.
We know that this
is at most n over 2
because we know that at
most half of the weight
lives in the light child.
Now these get recursively
visited at most four times,
up to four times.
Worst case, it
will be four times.
In this recurrence, this
first term doesn't matter.
R of n is at most
R of n minus 1.
Yeah, big deal.
That's just saying R
of n increases with n.
So really, this is going to be--
and then the max disappears.
All we need is this is at
most 4 times R of n over 2.
And this is a recurrence.
If you read CLRS, this
follows the master theorem
and you know immediately
this is order n squared.
It'd be theta n squared,
but this is an upper bound.
In the worst case, it will
actually be theta n squared.
So the amount of refinement
is at most n squared.
If this is not obvious
to you, an easy way
to imagine it is you start
with something of size n,
you're visiting four times
something of size n over 2.
This is called a recurrence
tree, recursion tree.
Each of these visits four
times something of size
n over 4 and so on.
Obviously, log n levels here.
And at the bottom, you're
going to have a bunch of ones.
That's when you stop recursing.
And if you add up
everything level
by level, how much
work am I doing here
and how much work
am I doing here?
2n.
How much work am I doing here?
It gets harder to add,
but there are 4 squared,
16 things, each n over 4.
So it's 4n.
In general, it goes up by
a factor of 2 every time
which means you're
dominated by the last layer.
And if you count, it's
going to be n squared
because this is 2 to the
0, 2 to the 1, 2 to the 2.
After you get to log n,
it's 2 to the log n times n,
so that is n squared.
And this is a
geometric series if you
want to add all
these numbers up.
And so it's 2 times n squared.
So that's the
proof of this bound
and that's how you get
quadratic refinement.
So either idea is kind
of easy, but the two
together, pretty powerful.
Questions about unfolding?
I think this algorithm
should be pretty clear.
One of the questions
was, are they practical?
I think the answer is no.
It has the same issue of
strip folding from origami.
But I think they would
make great animations.
This is still a cool
project to see virtually.
But to do it physically
is probably crazy.
No one has tried
as far as I know.
Another idea.
This is an open problem.
So orthogonal was great.
It has all these
nice properties.
Can you generalize it, not
to arbitrary polyhedra,
but to some other
kind of orthogonal,
such as this is a
hexagonal lattice in 3D?
I mean, it's just
extruded in one dimension,
but then you have hex
grid in another dimension.
You could try to do that.
And my guess is if
you set up the bands
to be in hex dimensions, it
just works, but I haven't tried.
There's potentially some
low-hanging fruit here.
There should be other 3D
structures that might work.
A typical one in
computational geometry
is called c-oriented
polyhedra where here we
have three oriented polyhedra.
There's three
different directions
that the faces can
be perpendicular to.
Take 10 of them, can you
apply the same technique?
That gets dicier.
But something like this I
feel like may be possible.
You should try it out.
But as far as I know,
this is all open.
Last question is
Cauchy's rigidity theorem
seems intuitively obvious.
Or as I wrote it in the notes,
is Cauchey's rigidity theorem
obvious?
And my answer is no,
not obvious to me.
I have two reasons
why it's not obvious.
One is it's not true
in two dimensions.
That's kind of a weak statement.
But if I take a convex
polyhedron in 2D--
so these are rigid faces.
This is the equivalent
of a triangle.
This is not rigid, of course.
So that's one statement.
And then the other thing
is convexity is necessary.
There's this thing,
Steffen's polyhedron.
Actually, originally, there
was a Connelly polyhedron.
We've seen some
results by Connelly.
He's a rigidity expert.
And then this was
simplified by this guy Klaus
Steffen in the '70s.
This is a drawing
of it flexing in 3D.
Nonconvex polyhedra
can be flexible.
They happen to preserve
their volume as they flex.
It's hard to say why a
theorem is not obvious.
To me, it's not obvious.
Of course, if you play
with convex polyhedra,
they are rigid, so maybe
it's obvious from that.
But you've got to prove
experimental evidence
mathematically.
Other questions?
Then I have some fun
videos to show you.
The first one is the making
of this origami piece which
I've probably shown
a picture of before.
It's by Brian Chan.
It's one square paper, no cuts.
Mens et Manus with a little
crane instead of-- what's
it normally?
Who knows?
And then he also
made this nice box.
And then the glass is
etched by Peter Houk
who runs the glass lab at MIT.